Okay, good morning all of you.
So I'm going to talk about deep learning in particular the transfer learning from deep
pretend models.
So transfer learning has a very long history and I'm not going to talk about the other
kinds of transfer learning but I'm primarily going to focus on the kind of transfer learning
that we do from deep learning models.
So I will briefly touch upon what is transfer learning and then I'll directly come into
the deep learning best models and try to show you what are the things that we do in deep
learning to transfer, what are the different challenges, the computational issues, the
changes that you need to make in the model parameters, the model architectures, some
applications of transfer learning and then I will end up with some of the very well known
open source pretend models which are the backbone of any kind of transfer learning in deep learning.
So before I get into transfer learning I quickly review the deep nets because this is something
on which we will be standing our entire talk, so the foundation for the kind of talk that
we are going to do today.
So as you know the deep learnings are extremely effective, so sorry there is a spelling mistake
it should be effective primarily because they can learn representation automatically for
specific tasks.
So if you recall the conventional machine learning, the traditional machine learning what happens
in this case that the future engineering is typically done by the human expert, somebody
who knows the domain, for example somebody who understand image very well or somebody
who understand the language very well, so they can extract the features from the corresponding
domain and then it comes to the typical machine learning models like support vector machine,
logistic regression, decision tree and all sorts of things.
The good thing about deep learning is that we do not need to do all kinds of stuff, the
future engineering is done automatically, specific to a particular task, the model itself
will learn the representation based on the data and based on the objective function that
we have, so that gives the power, the main power.
So very little or no manual intervention required and I will come to this particular point when
I talk about things where we need very little or very little manual intervention in situation
like this.
So the typical structure I believe this people have been talking about these things for quite
some time in the last few lectures, I just quickly give the basics of these deep nets.
So deep net is nothing but a very big and complex mathematical function and typically
they have millions and billions of parameters which we call weights and biases and so on
and so forth.
And the parameters they do everything for you.
So they are the real workhorse for all the things that you did learning.
So if you get them right then they can do good things for you.
So in order to get them right we need to train these things very nicely and that itself is
a very big challenge not only computationally but at the same time it requires lot of data
to do it.
And one of these major motivations for using transfer learning is to minimize the necessity
of data and we would like to transfer a particular knowledge or representation from the other
domains and try to adapt it.
Now all of you probably know that there are various kinds of deep nets.
First that comes to our mind is the vanilla neural network which we also call the feed
forward neural network.
So basically what you have you have that all the layers are connected with the next layer
and also and so forth fully connected layers and you simply perform computation from left
to right and predict something.
So this is good for the tabular data.
We assume that the features are already in good form and we can do lots of the traditional
tasks that the conventional machine learning people do.
The second most important thing is the convolutional neural network.
So this kind of neural network is very useful for image and video data.
In this case we need much more sophisticated future engineering than the tabular data.
So we have lot of layers you know these convolutional layers, max pooling layers, fully connected
layers and all sorts of things and they will extract some interesting features for the task
that we are dealing with and then they can do the magic for you.
The third category of models recurrent neural nets specifically for temporal data.
So by temporal data I mean the time series data or where the things have sequences.
For example the natural language text which is a very good example of sequence data because
the words are dependent and if you change the word the order of different words then
they can carry different meanings.
So for those kind of tasks for example something that you have to deal with the natural languages
the recurrent neural nets are extremely good models.
Now more recently and I think something that is ruling the entire deep learning community
is the attention based nets in particular the transformer and its different variants.
So unlike recurrent neural nets they are not that recursively dependent different states.
This can be done in parallel with the concept called self-attention which can capture extremely
powerful dependencies between different symbols appeared in the input data and then you can
basically do all sorts of things.
So the generative BI for example the chat GPT and other things essentially relying on
the transformer model.
In all of these cases we will see how these architectures can be changed or modified to
achieve the transfer learning.
So the essence of deep learning is basically representation learning.
So that's the power main power of deep learning.
So the input data could be like image, video, text or audio and then you have this model
involving a billion sometimes millions and billions of parameters and they will produce
a hidden vector of some dimension fixed dimension typically the numerical the real number vectors
and these vectors will finally help us to produce the final output.
Now the vectors that we get from these models is not human understandable in the sense that
if we try we cannot really make sense out of it.
So all the machines do they know that how this can be used different models the computational
models they understand how this can be used to achieve the final goal.
So to give you a little bit of sense of these vectors created by the deep learning models.
So ultimately what they do they follow discriminative sort of the learning paradigm.
So if two objects are very different to each other then the vectors produced by the deep
learning models will be very different so angle between them will be very high or distance
between them will be very high or something like that.
So the typical deep learning model as I mentioned will involve a millions and billions of parameters
you know and these parameters typically are organized in a particular way so that you
can do the lot of feature engineering and so on and so forth.
So whenever I talk about the parameters I will denote by this set of parameters W typically
the weights and B for the biases.
So typically these two sets of parameters that you have in the deep learning models will
determine everything for you.
So general belief is that higher the number of parameters better capability that they
have but the downside is that higher the model more computational power will be required
more data will be required and that is where transfer learning comes into picture.
The first question that we encounter in transfer learning why transfer learning.
So the first assumption on which transfer learning stands is that there are many tasks
that we do often they share common knowledge.
For example the linguistic representations of text fragments will share some common things
and that can be exploited to achieve different text processing applications.
For example if we are dealing with say natural language text we may need to classify the
particular text into a particular category.
We may need to group the text in different groups.
We may need to find out the orientation of the text for example whether this is positive
or negative and so on and so forth.
So although they have different tasks they do share the common linguistic characteristics
that can be exploited in this case.
Now coming to images for example many images will share the structural similarities.
For example the shape of an image is an extremely powerful signal which can be used to do many
downstream tasks for example image classification, image captioning, segmentation and so on and
so forth.
Now the same feature for example in case of image the edges can be used to many other
domains.
So the question is why can't we exploit the common representation that the tasks share
so that we can minimize the computational requirements, we can minimize the necessity
of data and so on and so forth.
The second and one of the most important sort of the motivations behind transfer learning
is the annotation cost of data.
So in order to train a very big deep net you require a lot of data and often the data requires
annotation and the annotation is not only time consuming at the same time it's expensive
and at the same time more data that you have there will be a lot of noise and processing
pre-processing data and cleaning up things will also be extremely challenging.
So what we do we basically make use of HMAS supervision as available to us and then try
to modify on top of this sitting on top of this to achieve something.
The third important point is building large models from scratch is extremely time consuming.
They are computationally very heavy.
So not only computationally very heavy they also consume a lot of power so that also is
kind of damaging for the environment, generates a lot of carbon, footprints and so on so forth.
So for many different perspective that if you could minimize the computational burden
for training the deep networks we can do lot of good things and this is one of the major
objectives of the transfer learning that we are dealing with.
Now to give a pictorial view of transfer learning.
Now on the left side you can see the traditional machine learning model.
So you have different tasks for example task 1, task 2, task 3 and then you have annotated
data for example.
These are the annotated data that you have.
So all the data annotations for different tasks and then there is a model, the different
learning systems for different data and so on so forth.
And for each task the machine learning model will learn a new model based on the task and
the data and they do not share anything between themselves.
And contrast in transfer learning what happens is that say you have a source task and then
you have some annotated data in the source task we know and then you have another target
task for which we do not have annotated data.
So something that we learn from the source task for example in terms of knowledge in
terms of particular system and also on so forth can be exploited in this case.
So we are not going to train the models from scratch every time we encounter a new task.
What we do we try to figure out often what is the closest possible existing task where
the model is there.
Do they share any structural similarity, semantic similarity if the answer is yes.
We will take that the existing model we will try to modify this in some way or the other
and then we basically try to apply this on a new task.
Now of course there are a lot of downsides of it and I will discuss while I talk about
all of these things later on in few minutes.
So what are the key questions in transfer learning?
The first question is what to transfer.
So it is not very easy that you take something and then go and straight away apply on a new
task and so on so forth.
So that may not give you the desired result.
So the first question that we should be asking ourselves what to transfer.
So in doing so what we need to do we need to identify which portion of knowledge is source
specific and what is common between the source and the target.
So once you identify that then you can target that common representation of the common knowledge
and modify with respect to the task that we are dealing with and so little bit of like
changes we can made to the big existing model.
The second question went to transfer.
So the ultimate objective is to improve in some way or the other.
Computationally of course we do not want to degrade the accuracy substantially that something
has to be kept in mind.
So our objective would be to utilize transfer learning to improve the target tasks and results
and we certainly do not want to degrade them.
So then we have to basically keep in mind when we can do the transfer learning so that
we can achieve this one.
Now when I am saying that not degrade them that means I am not saying that you cannot
degrade them numerically.
So even if like often in fact we will see that the transfer learning models they do degrade
performance if you transfer the knowledge compared to if you try to do things from scratch
using lot of data and big models.
But the amount of degradation should be minimal.
If there is substantial amount of degradation then the transfer learning is not going to
serve the purpose.
And the third question is the technical question of building these models, training these models
and all of these things how to transfer.
So we have to transfer one model to the other tasks and therefore what are the changes that
you have to make to the existing algorithms and different techniques and how you can train
and re-train them what are the minimal amount of data that we make use of, computational
challenges and so on so forth.
So these three key questions that we need to be very clear about before we try to apply
transfer learning.
So these pictures give you the sort of this taxonomy of transfer learning strategies.
So the lot of things that we know about transfer learning and depending upon the availability
of data we can categorize a particular thing into a particular category.
So first of all that we can assume that the label data are available in a target domain.
So we have a source domain, that's the paradigm we are operating on and we have a target domain.
And the source domain basically something where we have the original model in this case.
Then the models comes to the target domain, basically we will try to apply for this one.
So all basically we are going to do, we are going to this particular model that we have
in the source domain and in this case if we have some label data available in the target
domain what we should do.
So in a setup like this we can apply inductive transfer learning.
So inductive transfer learning again there are various cases.
So no label data in a source domain, so what we do we apply something like the source self
transfer learning, in case we have the label data available in the source domain we can
apply the kind of learning where the source and the target tasks can be learned simultaneously.
And all of the things that we do in this case is called multi task learning and I will touch
upon that particular issue later in this particular lecture.
In the second scenario the label data are available only in a source domain and the
no label data available in the target domain.
In a situation like that what we can do, we can do transductive transfer learning, this
another branch of transfer learning.
So the main assumption that we make in this case is that the different domains but single
task, the same task but the domains are different.
So what we can do, we can do a thing called the domain adaptation.
The other assumption that we can make is that the single domain and single task, then in
that case also we can do the sample selection bias, there could be a lot of issues sample
selection bias, covariance shift and so on and so forth.
The third situation in transfer learning the no label data in both source and target domain.
So in neither of these domain the label data available.
So in this particular situation we simply do the unsupervised transfer learning, no label
data is typically used and we can basically transfer one model, the source model to the
target domain without using any kind of data.
Now coming to the transfer learning, so again I would like to reiterate that you learn one
particular task and then transfer to another task.
So that is the kind of setup we are operating on.
So broadly we have two major components for this one.
One is pre-training a particular model and then we would like to adopt this particular
model for the kind of application we are targeting.
So pre-training will give you the initial base model on top of which we will be standing
and modifying.
So I am just showing few examples, there are a lot of examples one can pick.
So one of the oldest thing in somewhat close to deep learning is what to make.
So the objective was to create the vectors of the words from a natural language text.
This is one of the pre-trained model in unsupervised training is done based on a very big natural
language corpus and then at the end of it we create a vectors for each of these words
in a particular language.
The objective is basically if two words are appearing in different context in a big corpus
then the vectors between them should have very high angle.
If they are appearing in the same context that means probably they are meaningfully same.
So the vectors should have very small angle between them.
GPT is something that we all know, so it is a transformer based model created by OpenAI
and that is something we like everybody is using nowadays.
So that again is a language model which is trained on a very huge volume of data of different
tasks and so on and so forth and at the end of it we have a language model, again it is
a vector manipulation on all sorts of things.
But the bi-regional transformer which is basically the backbone of GPT and all modern language
models in deep learning.
So again you go and create the hidden representations for different words, sentences, paragraphs
and so on and so forth.
So these are all like some of the pre-trained models available and given a particular task
for example say I would like to achieve classification on text or say I would like to perform classification
on the product reviews or I would like to classification say news items and all sorts
of things.
So which is a kind of supervised learning setup and often you need lot of data to do
that.
So what we can do basically we can choose one of the speed and models like what to make
GPT or BART and then you can use little bit of data from classification, the domain of
classification we are targeting, we modify this particular vectors little bit and get
things done.
Similarly question answering is also another popular task, extremely powerful task in NLP
and what we do basically we take these vectors and then we can basically modify these vectors
based on the questions and the answers that we have and build our new models.
Text leveling for example if you give a particular sequence, for example you spot the name, dentities
in a text and so on.
So how you can basically do that leveling task and so on.
So one thing I once again re-iter and that is very important to remember is that in deep
learning is basically the objective is to do given the input data we would like to give
the end goal, I mean end task.
But in the middle the entire the objective of training, processing and everything goes
into creating the good high quality vectors from the raw data.
So everything that you do in deep learning is in vector form.
So image is converted to vector, audio is converted to vector, text is converted to
vector, video is converted to vector, vectors of real numbers, that is what the machines
can understand and all we do basically we take the input data convert this into vector
and then we use this vector to achieve the final goal.
So the vector does not make any sense to a human being, not understandable because often
this is very high dimensional but what we know is that if two things are different the
angles between or the distance between these two vectors will be different, that's all
we know and then on top of this basically we can apply some kind of this mathematical
models to predict the final end goal.
So coming to the pre-training in little bit of more detail, so one is basically unlabeled
data and cell supervision and that is something extremely very popular nowadays because the
unlabeled data is widely available on the web elsewhere and when we have to do pre-training
based on the unlabeled data we have to apply the self-supervision mode, we cannot do supervised
mode.
So for example it is easy to gather the large corpus from Wikipedia, news, web crawls, social
media and et cetera, et cetera, anybody can go and crawl the data, you do not need any
kind of supervision to do that, you also do not need any kind of annotation, so you simply
go and pick them up.
So what the main, the hypothesis behind this approach is that the training assumes that
the things which are appearing in the same context are distributionally similar, which
is called distributional hypothesis.
So in supervised pre-training, which is pretty common in computer vision, so what we have
is essentially that computer vision, machine translation and so on and so forth.
So we have explicit access to the training data in the sense that we have the original
input data, say for example an image and its corresponding levels, say for example this
is cat, this is dog, this is human being, this is a green field and so on and so forth.
So we have explicit access to all the data that we have and the levels which you can
make use of.
Now in machine translation for example we have the source language text, say in English
we have the corresponding translation available in target language, say for example in Hindi
or in Bengali and then we can basically make use of to learn the association between the
source language and the target language.
In question answering for example, say we have some question answering data set in say
news for example, news domain, then can we basically use that same thing, similar thing
in medical domain for example.
So all of these things can be done through the supervised pre-training.
Now self-supervision is something extremely powerful and most of the today's the big language
models are basically driven by the self-supervised paradigm.
And so I will talk about those things later in this particular lecture.
So for example, the BART, GPT and all of these things they use huge amount of self-supervision
while they are learning these models.
So just to give you a little bit of sense and I believe deep learning basics have been covered
in this particular series and I would like to briefly touch upon that just to make things
little like continuous between different lectures.
So word embedding methods, what they do, they learn one vector per word and fixed dimensional
vectors.
So every word will be converted to a fixed dimensional vector.
So all of these entries, this is 0.9, this is 0.1 and so on so forth.
So all these vectors will have some, all the real number vectors.
And the objective as I mentioned is that, that if two words are meaningfully, semantically
not similar, they must have different vectors.
That's all we know.
If you try to make some sense out of these vectors, that is going to be challenging because
you do not know what they are.
But you can do some kind of processing like these computing similarity, computing distances
and so on so forth and you try to understand that the quality of vectors and so on so forth.
So they are once again relying on the distributional assumptions in deep learning, or in most of
the language processing tasks, that if two words are distributionally similar in terms
of the context, they should have the same vectors.
And the vectors will have the same dimension.
So for example, this is another example, so we have vectors like for example cat and dog
and so on so forth.
And we have a sentence like say, I love my cat and dog.
And we like to basically, you know, annotate this data, like for example, we would like
to tag this particular sequence of things in terms of verbs, in terms of, for example,
the nouns and so on so forth, which we can parse with this tagging.
And in this kind of application, we can actually make use of these vectors that we have.
So as I mentioned, the things basically are not very independent.
So for example, the meanings of words again, context dependent.
So in the previous case, typically what we do, we create one vector for each word, you
know, from a very large corpus, we train it, then we get the vectors and so on so forth.
But that has very limited application and utility in the sense that in language, often
the words and the meanings are basically they depend on the context in which they are appearing.
So these two sentences make things very clear that we have two cats or it is running cats
and dogs.
So what ideally we should be doing in a situation like this, we must have the different vectors
for the word cats because they are appearing in different context.
So these are basically some of these examples.
We are moving from the fixed vector to, for example, these words in context and we will
adapt these kind of vectors to make sure that they represent the context adequately.
So language modeling is something that we apply a lot and all generative say these models
that we see today, GPT, question answering, all sorts of things, they essentially rely
on the language modeling.
So to simply define this term language modeling, we like to learn the probability of a piece
of text that we see or we generate.
The simple example is, for example, when you are typing something on say word, MS word,
if you make some mistake, for example, you've forgotten a particular article or preposition,
you wrongly use some say tense of a particular verb and all sorts of things, the system will
flag it that this is not the right thing to do.
So how do they understand?
The simple logic is that, that they use a huge volume of say clean text, the correct
language text and they try to understand that given some text, what is the probability
that the next word or some other word appearing in the text basically, you know, happened
in the text that we have seen so far in a clean text.
So if this is linguistically correct thing to do, then the probability of the text that
you are trying to predict for would be extremely high given the other text.
If not, they are going to be wrong.
So they will generate some kind of probability distribution given some text, whether this
is possible to generate the other text and so on and so forth.
And all these models that we do right now, the GPT, the transformers and all sorts of
things essentially make the model language in a specific way so that they can solve the
target purpose.
So the good thing about this one is that, that it doesn't require any human annotation.
We can go and collect good quality text, for example, the news items and all so on and
so forth and we can basically use those things straightaway without requiring any manual intervention.
And so typically like languages, every language that we know, most of these popular languages,
they have enough text available and that actually helps us to learn the high capacity model
because all these models will require lot of data to train rightly.
Okay now, deep learning models are basically, as I mentioned previously, that they are full
of parameters.
Okay?
They are a very big mathematical models.
The mathematics is simple, but the way things are organized often not that easily understandable
to human being.
Like we understand little bit partly or some like, you know, what we are trying to do in
a particular neuron or so on and so forth, but we don't fully understand what they do
at the end of it.
But intuitively what we typically try to do is that, that we try to combine the raw data
in a form which will help us to achieve the end goal.
And the combination only takes place through some mathematical models.
For example, the linear regression, what we typically do is assume that this basically
the final prediction will depend on the linear combination of the input features.
Okay?
Or a logistic regression, what we assume is that, that the things can be separated using
a linear decision boundary and so on and so forth.
So under any deep learning model, we make certain assumptions, okay?
And then we basically try and explore and try to see whether this is serving our purpose
for the end goal, okay?
So one of the very fast model in language modeling is basically this created by the Benjiro,
one of the pioneers of modern AI.
So in this case, what they did, they basically used a very shallow neural network using this
different words, what you can see that different words here, okay?
And then using this context, they are trying to create, for example, this probability of
a particular word appearing in a particular situation, given the context vector, okay?
So the context in this case is basically a vector, okay?
So the context of a particular vector, we encode the entire thing in the form of a vector
of some dimension.
And given this particular vector, is it possible to generate a particular word?
And we simply try to measure the similarity.
If the similarity is very high, that means the context can rightly generate the word
and therefore the word can be placed in this particular position, okay?
If the probability is low, then we know that context is not capable of generating the particular
word and something is wrong, so we flag it, okay?
So that's the kind of shallow network that the initial model that people have developed.
Now of course the shallow networks have a lot of limitations because they are not able
to capture extremely intricate complex dependencies between different things, okay?
Now stepping aside for a moment, if we pose this question even to somebody who understand
human language very well, that if you give him a piece of text and ask him to say whether
this text is reflecting a positive thing about somebody or a negative thing about somebody,
okay?
Now anybody who understand language little bit, he or she should be able to answer this
question straight away that this is positive, this is negative and all sorts of because
we have some prior knowledge about the language we are dealing with.
Now the moment you ask the human being the same person that how did you decide it, okay?
You tell us a methodology through which you have decided this is negative but this is
positive.
It is very difficult and nearly impossible to come up with a particular method and algorithm
to tell that this is the way I have decided it, okay?
Therefore you cannot teach that particular thing to somebody that this is how you should
take the decision.
So in a nutshell, we are very good at doing the end goal, okay?
On the input data but we do not understand the internal mechanism through which we achieve
this, okay?
And that is where all these deep models comes into picture.
So now how to achieve this one?
The only thing that we have here some numbers because machines have machine only understand
numbers and then from one set of numbers we would like to achieve another set of numbers.
So the only way you can manipulate these things through mathematical models and to combine
different things in a particular way and a layer basically nothing but combines information
in a particular way.
So more layers means more combination.
More combinations means more intricate dependencies, okay?
So for example, when you are trying to judge the orientation of a particular sentence,
then there could be three, four words in a particular sentence which in combination will
help us decide that this is negative, this is positive.
So you need to capture that kind of dependencies.
So the deep models that we basically often play with is very good at capturing those kind
of dependencies.
So the typical assumption behind most of the deep learning models is that they deeper the
models and better they are in capturing those kind of dependencies.
So we basically then explored these deeper models and something that is extremely popular
is called BART is a bi-directional encoder from transformers.
So once again is primarily for the language processing tasks but people also apply this
on images as well.
So there they use multiple layers to capture many kind of dependencies using attentions
and so on and so forth.
Okay, now we talked about the embedding of words and all deep learning models essentially
embed words or text.
So once again, the embedding means that a vector representing a particular word, sentence
or anything like for image or everything else.
And that's the main building block of this deep learning, modern deep learning models
and AI models.
The question is why embedding?
I mean why we really would like to do embedding of words, images and all sorts of things.
So the fundamental assumption behind embedding is that the embeddings are basically parameters
okay and they are unknown initially and therefore we can use some learning mechanism to learn
them okay.
So they are learnable and that basically gives us the main power from the raw data.
Second thing is that there are many tasks that we deal with often, they share representations
okay.
So if that is the case, then why not simply use these embeddings from one task to another
one okay.
And third and most importantly, embedding typically gives you a lower dimensional compact
vector, dense vectors okay, say 100, 200, 300 so on and so forth okay.
And most of the entries in these vectors have some non-zero numerical value okay, that's
why you call dense vectors and that makes the things very efficient you know.
We can efficiently manipulate these things because at the end of anything we have to
compute the similarities between different vectors.
So if we have these small dimensional vectors with like the compact dense vectors then you
can manipulate them efficiently and this gives us computational power okay.
So coming back to our previous one, the neural language modeling stuff.
So we basically pre-tend the language and then create these word vectors.
So we call it pre-tend word vectors and so on and so forth.
This is one architecturally extremely popular.
The other kind of stuff that we know of is like multitask word embeddings okay.
So in multitask word embedding, what happens is that we simultaneously try to learn embeddings
okay for different tasks.
And as you know that basically we use different kinds of layers.
So I believe that in our previous lectures on deep learning touched upon different kinds
of layers.
So for example, so this is one architecture and there is no end of variation of different
architectures okay.
So this is one architectures that work pretty well.
So convolutional layer followed by the max pooling layer, followed by the classical, the
fully connected layer, then softmax layer and so on and so forth.
So at the very fast layer okay, what you have the input data okay.
So if you are dealing with languages, you can give the words in a sentences or in paragraphs
and so on and so forth.
If you are dealing with images, then you can give images.
If you have audio signals, you can give audio signals something like that.
And on top of this basically you apply many many layers.
So in this particular architecture, they decided to use convolution, then max pooling, then
the fully connected layer, then the softmax layer and finally the end goal okay.
And because the two tasks are being learned simultaneously in this particular setup, we
are calling this multitask learning and in this way for example, if you apply this one
a language processing tasks, we can get the embeddings based on this multitask learning.
So these other important things, sentence and document vectors, you know, not only that
what vectors we deal with, we also deal with sentence and document vectors okay.
So this is one of the very oldest, very old work on the unsupervised paragraph embedding.
So what we have in this case that we would like to, so basically do the paragraph embedding
using a distributed memory.
So we basically feed the entire paragraph to a particular model and then we create this
word vectors and so on and so forth.
We create some kind of average of this word vectors and finally produce this final output
okay.
There are other approaches as well that people have followed but the broad goal of this one
is basically given a piece of text is a paragraph typically, we would like to create a vector
which will represent the meaning or semantics whatever you can call it of the piece of text
given in the paragraph okay.
Just like the word embedding, you have the paragraph embedding and this is pretty common
in the modern AI NLP.
Now another popular task, next sentence prediction.
So you have a sentence okay and then you would like to see whether the next sentence is coherent
with the previous sentence.
Now often when we write like the languages like say paragraphs and all sorts of things
and so on and so forth, it is important to understand whether the sentence which is coming
next is a good one compared to the like given the context that we are dealing with okay.
So for this kind of stuff what we need to have, we need to have an architecture say
for example this is the previous sentence okay and given the previous sentence, we like
to predict the next sentence that means the words of next sentence and whether they could
basically come next okay and this kind of model so called the sequence to sequence model.
Now we also do pre training on auto encoders okay so auto encoders means that I do not
need any supervised data to create the encodings or encodings of the original data.
So what we try to do basically we have some input data and how we can represent for example
in this case this is the input data and then what model we can learn from this so that
the model will again generate the original data.
That is why we are calling this an auto encoder you know I do not need any supervised learning
setup I do not need any annotated data nothing like that so it will just convert the original
data into a vector form and again we will use that vector form to generate the original
data in the same form.
So if the new data that we generate from the original data can be generated very nicely
or as is then the encoding that we have generated is a good one okay and that is also very popular
very well known approach in pre training you know unsupervised pre training where no manual
intervention required at all okay.
All what vectors once again the real power house for all modern the language processing
tasks you know GPT and all sorts of things that we see okay.
So this is for example you know one such example taken from a particular vector created by
one of the very popular molecular glove so these are the basically the nearest neighbor
vectors for word play you know verbs are basically playing played nouns are game games players
football adjective multiplayer and so on so forth.
So if you like to answer the question something like that given a particular word find out
different sorts of things parser speech etcetera which are very close to this particular word
then you can actually use this pre trained word vectors to achieve this goal okay.
Once again basically we apply the contextual word vectors okay not a fixed word vector
for a particular word in a given language.
Now the key idea in context vector is this okay.
So instead of learning one vector per word we like to learn a vector that depends on
the context okay.
So for example in this case so given the context the kids play a game in the park so this is
my context the text context given okay.
I like to learn a vector for word play this must be unequal to the vector that you get
if the context is the broad way play premiered yesterday okay.
So although the word we are interested in play for which we would like to create context
vector the context are different and therefore the vector should be different and that is
extremely useful to capture the meaning of text because text is basically very difficult
to understand often because of its varying semantics depending upon the situation and
so on so forth okay and for this like there are many approaches in fact load of language
models are available using deep learnings where things are used to create the context
vector contextual vector for different words okay and that helps us to determine the meanings
of different things and very useful in application like question answering reasoning and all
sorts of things okay.
So one of the interesting architectures is tag LM so tag language model and I will always
use this like this you know acronym LM for language modeling next onwards.
So in this case what they are trying to do they pre-train two language models one in
forward direction another in backward direction okay so there are two language models that
we have in this case so this is the forward direction language model this is the backward
direction language model okay and then we are basically using these things to a sequence
tagger for example that we would like to tag a particular sentence like their parser speech
and so on and so forth okay.
So the reason that we do it because we would like to capture the context from both direction
okay typically if you go from one direction to the other left right for example you can
capture the left context very nicely but we may not be able to capture the right context
so we need to basically capture this one.
So what this particular model has done they have taken two identical language models the
sequence models okay but the way they have used this raw data okay is something like
this and one model will take the context from left to right the other model will take the
context from right to left so the model will generate two kinds of vector for each word
because they have two different contexts and then we combine these two vectors to produce
a final vector for each of these words and then we use this for any downstream task like
sequence tagging and semantics and all other things okay.
So in these two situations so we basically use this context vector to speed up things
to achieve other things and so on and so forth okay so unsupervised pre-training for sequence
to sequence models so we have say for example we have the pre-training encoder and decoder
with language models so in this case we basically have this encoding and then decoding and we
have multiple layers of this particular model and often we use a softmax layer at the end
of it that's pretty common which is just before the prediction layer and so on so forth.
Quickly coming to GPT something is ruling the world so we also heavily rely on these
pre-trained models so it's a very complex model based on transformer so we have so
on the left side what we can see is basically the transformer block I'm not getting into
details of transformer because that is something probably will be covered in language modeling
thing so just to give you a sense of what it is without getting into the details a transformer
is basically a very complex combination of different layers okay so you have the embedding
layers where you are taking these embeddings of these words then you try to see the similarity
between different embeddings then you combine weights with this one so on so forth you normalize
these things little bit then you apply a feed forward network so that you can exchange information
then you apply layer normalization to squash this values little bit and so on so forth and
then you stack up multiple such things in this case 12 such things you stack up to produce
this final thing okay and these vectors the final vectors produced by GPT is typically
used for many many different applications for example classification entailment computing
similarity between takes to understand whether they reflect the same thing or not answering
multiple size questions fill in the blanks and all sorts of things okay and the GPT something
is basically you know although they do use some level of supervision but bulk of the
thing that in GPT uses basically the unsupervised data okay data without any annotation from
the raw text okay so quickly coming to BART architecture so again I am not getting into
details of BART because that is not within the scope of my particular lecture but just
to give you a sense of what they do so in pre training what we do basically you know BART
is again bidirectional transformer so you use the same architecture but once again you
take from left to right left context and then from the right context and then you basically
mask few words okay and try to predict those masks word so nicely and so how we can adjust
this vectors so that we can create those things okay and then basically we can go and fine
tune these vectors because they are all generic fine tune these vectors for individual tasks
for example question answering, name data recognition, language understanding and all
sorts of things okay now okay now I will come to one of the most important part of
this transfer learning which is adaptation and in this particular segment I will talk
about how to actually adapt different models existing models depending up on the tasks
that you are dealing with okay so before we get into that we take a short break and then
we come back and talk about different approaches for adaptation.